so this is about Nigel farage who is
well he's an amateur broadcaster and his
new life but he is also a well-known
politician now he claimed that documents
have proved that cootsbank have closed
his account due to his views on brexit
Donald Trump and gender ideology the
bank whose clients include members of
the royal family and myself initially
denied that was the case and brief that
perhaps farage didn't have enough money
he could have a certain amount of money
to have a Coots account but according to
the former brexit party leader 10 other
banks have refused his custom prime
minister Rishi sunak has condemned it
today stated that no one should be
barred from using basic services for
their political reviews adding a free
speech as a Cornerstone to our democracy
so Grace an interesting case
when you get into the weeds of the
documents which were published by the
telegraph today it's the reasons
apparently are twofold one is that uh
Nigel's says I want to make you aware of
a commercial exit decision being made
about uh Nigel farage the relationship
has been below commercial criteria for
some time and upon review of Nigel's
past public profile connections the
perceived risk for the future waiting
against the benefit of attention the
decision was taken to exit upon
repayment of an existing mortgage now it
turned out that that existing was
apparently was paid off hence their
decision to say we're no longer going to
allow them to become a to stay as a
client did they make a decision risk
factors included accusations of links to
Russia controversial public statements
which were left to conflict with the
bank's purpose and the possibility
speculated in the press and not denied
of re-entry to politics taken into
account there is however also clearly a
risk of negative publicity in exiting
which was accepted so that's the broad
brush Strokes here where partly they've
used the excuse he no longer has them
amount of money you need to have a coup
to Gap I can attest thing you have a
certain amount so that may be partly
true but clearly another motivating
factor were his political views to which
I would say I don't agree with a lot of
what Nigel farage says politically but I
don't understand why he shouldn't be
allowed an accountant Coots if I am well
I have strong opinions about awesome
things
um Mr farage believes in a free market
and businesses within a free market have
the right to make decisions about
services and go to the willow what is
that right based on supply and demand
should a major Bank be using someone's
political views I mean look they his
relationship with Donald Trump Donald
Trump the market doesn't care about your
feelings the market doesn't care about
anything it is just risk and reward it's
supply and demand and if you believe in
a world that is governed by the logic of
the market you have absence
of course but the market doesn't
guarantee the market doesn't guarantee
you know who has the public said
and if it was up to me I believe we
should have a public banking system in
which everyone is guaranteed different
issues it is a very just to clarify just
to clarify you think should have the
right to do is fine I don't believe that
because I don't believe in a free market
okay but Nigel farage does but do you
believe that Nigel Farah should be
disallowed or have his account
discontinued because of his political
views given your adherence to free
speech you've just been banging all
about I think that we should have a
public banking system in which everyone
is
de facto should he be allowed to have an
accountant coot because of historical
view we live in a capitalist economy if
a private bank says because of perceived
political risk we aren't going to give
an account to someone then ultimately
either you say we live in a free market
Society they have the right to do that
or you say we shouldn't live in a
freezer and he shouldn't have the right
not free speech okay
it doesn't guarantee free speech I
understood
before you speak
talking about this and then come to you
commentary and behaviors that do not
align with the bank's purpose and values
have been demonstrated
so the bank has a series of values the
bank has a series of political positions
and as for purpose well I thought the
purpose of companies was to act
ethically yes of course but to return to
their shareholders dividends and in this
case folks do you know who the
shareholders are it's you and me
all right Douglas your view of this
well first of all it's always uh
delicious when a socialist sets up a
binary uh in the way that Grace just did
if there's something bad in capitalism
the only alternative is socialism of
course it is it always is for socialists
isn't it but it is lovely here in Greece
I'm really not interrupting yourself
awareness
it's lovely hearing Grace defend Coots
bank it's a terrific position for a
socialist to be in uh look I would put
it the most important the most important
the most important thing in this is the
old shoe on the other foot uh scenario
isn't it appears here's here's a good
example I mean grace was a supporter of
Jeremy corbyn Jeremy corbyn led a very
racist period in the labor party's
history where female Jewish MPS were
hounded out of the party and the
equality and Human Rights Commission
found that the labor party had a serious
problem with racism now here's the thing
I don't agree with anything that Jeremy
corbyn believes probably enough no more
than I agree with anything that great
beliefs but if Coots bank I don't know
if Mr Corbin would bank with Coots but
whoever he banked with if they said that
because of Mr Corbin's association with
racists and racism and terrorists and so
on he shouldn't be allowed to have a
bank in the UK I would defend him to the
hilt because I know where this goes the
Canadian government uh Ultra dippy
Trudeau in Canada has presided over a
system in the last 18 months in which if
you're an opponent of his government and
actually come out and protest as people
did last year you can get debanked just
think about that again for a moment
we're talking about protests earlier
that if you protest against the
government you can lose the right to
Bank in the cashless economy so here's
the thing we know where this leads but
we know where this leads and I will
suggest that anyone who believes in
Freedom including freedom of the press
freedom of speech and much more should
care
critical suppose other people even when
they're political foes who they would
love to kick in the nuts get it they
should defend those people right how
might we have an economy in which
everyone has the right to a bank account
as a basic human right you have the
right to a bank account there's no way
you can get unbanked yeah
it clearly is that is a debate for
another day it's really not here's what
I was here's what I would say about
pertinence Nigel Farrell out of his way
to try and wreck my opening night
interview with Donald Trump for this
show a year ago he literally went to
Trump with all the worst things I said
about Trump in the previous year and
said look at this you can't do the
interview and Trump nearly pulled the
plug so I have absolutely zero reason to
say anything supportive of Nigel farage
and he works for a rival Network as a
amateur broadcaster
um again that's another reason not to
say anything nice about him however I've
got to say as a Coots customer myself I
find this very concerning and I rang
them today to ask I ran them to ask to
speak to them today when they they said
they couldn't talk about it because by
doing so they would be providing
information about a client I presume
they mean but here's my point about it I
have what some people consider
controversial views I don't think
they're controversial but I have quite
strong views about other things I'm not
quite sure why his are deemed less
acceptable in terms of being a banking
customer in the UK the mind I may not
agree with him about a number of things
I'm just not sure why I tick boxes and
he doesn't when it comes to a right to
have an opinion
a free democracy because it could be you
tomorrow appears it could be Grace the
day after me the day after that yeah
okay because based on an assessment of
risk which it has very professional
people to do they do it said it is going
to potentially over the Run damage our
profits if we offer this person this is
a decision every day no no
having read the full details appeared in
the telegraph today I don't think there
are grounds
but ultimately
public don't forget that coops lied and
briefed a lie to the BBC which the BBC
then reported they're not interested in
the truth that Coots I'd get your money
out peers
well we'll see I'm actually gonna I'm
gonna hope to speak to them and get some
answers to some questions I'm genuinely
interested and concerned about how far
they take this how far are my opinions
going to be one day right nationalized
raccoons right you know what goes
on the same page
as always thank you Irene Grace great to
see you twice running I'm spoiled uh
thank you thank you for being back today